représentant de la caisse d'allocations
familiales des yvelines de la
croix-rouge ou d'associations en faveur
des plus démunis
ce sont eux les premiers acteurs de la
lutte contre la pauvreté et notamment
celle des enfants en présence de la
ministre des solidarités de la santé ils
ont fait part de leurs connaissances et
de leurs attentes
on a toujours des attentes sur la
question de la parentalité de la petite
enfance
d'autant que c'est quand même le premier
pied à l'étrier je dirais sur le lien
social
c'est ce qui a été évoqué par madame la
ministre donc ça c'est déjà le premier
point de biens repréciser que faire
société
ça passe aussi et surtout parler tout
petit dans la tente et pouvoir peut-être
participer à des groupes de travail
parce qu'on a fait que évoqué ce matin
le sujet et qu'il faut approfondir en
france un enfant sur cinq vivraient sous
le seuil de pauvreté
cette journée marquait la première d'une
série de concertations lancées par le
gouvernement en octobre 2010 cet
objectif établir une stratégie de lutte
contre la pauvreté des enfants
nous voyons qu'il va falloir intervenir
sur le repérage l'identification des
besoins sur l'accès aux droits sur la
formation des professionnels
ce que je note
c'est une mobilisation et un engagement
très fort des acteurs de terrain avec
énormément d'initiatives locales
ça m'a permis de parler surtout des
dispositifs innovants en faveur de
l'enfance notamment l'espace bébé
parents qui est un lieu d'échangé lieu
d'accueil
un dispositif que la croix-rouge
souhaitent développer en milieu rural
sous une forme itinérante une dizaine
d'autres rencontres de ce type sont
prévues partout en france
remise de la stratégie adoptée à l'issue
de ces réunions prévues fin mars au
président de la république